flowery on the ball Raptors have two  timeouts siakam disrupts it lamb has it  throw it it goes  it goes a desperation free from the lamb  to win it but a Shaolin Hornets say what  wait come back for the raffles not leave  its fingers watch this great denial  right there lambs has got to throw it up  it's good jack in the Hornets winning  well  that was a remarkable play that ball was  in the air forever  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  the Hornets all-star justice players as  well look at it deep this he draws blame  at a perfect spot hold of follow-through  young fella given all one two three of  those that man has got some guts no shot  to bake sprite number three the Hornets  all-star justice players as well it is  deep 50 draws blame and a perfect spot  hold of follow-through young fella  give him all one two three of those